the oakland county circuit court is now
in session with the honorable kwame road
presiding thank you good afternoon
everyone appearances for the record when
you give your appearance please indicate
what the nitric extension procedure
jared mcdonald on is of the people and i
consent to the zone here
thank you mark keith on behalf of the
people we can send
good afternoon your honor assistant
prosecutor kelly collins appearing on
behalf of the people and i too consent
to zoom
good afternoon you're on our paulo
michelle on behalf of mr crumbly we are
consenting to proceeding by zoom
good afternoon your honor amy hop on
behalf of ethan crumley i consent to
zoom as well
good afternoon your honor deborah h
mckelvey court appointed guardian ad
litem for ethan crumbly and i have no
objections to proceeding with this
matter on zoom this afternoon
thank you good afternoon to all council
good afternoon mr crumbly mr crumbly can
you hear me sir
yes sir
you understand that you have a right to
be present in court today are you okay
with proceeding via zoom just for the
purposes of this arraignment
yes
thank you prior to calling this case the
court did have a brief breakout room
with the attorneys um i did discuss the
issue of any potential conflict as all
attorneys on the call are aware i am
was a former assistant prosecuting
attorney at the oakland county
prosecutor's office upon talking to
council i do not believe there's going
to be any conflict with me presiding
over this case is that correctness often
that is correct
any objection from any attorney on the
case of me presiding over it
not from the people judge
no your honor
thank you and with that being said the
court is comfortable with proceeding in
this matter and i don't believe there's
a conflict in this case today's date and
time set for an arraignment miss lofton
yes runner i would wave the formal
reading stand my client you ask that i'm
not guilty plea be entered
thank you the court will accept
jurisdiction enter a not guilty plea on
behalf of your client it's my
understanding that according to the
juvenile justice and delinquency
prevention act that a hearing must be
held before january 21st 2022 regarding
the placement of the defendant however
because of the pandemic we cannot
effectuate an in-person hearing um which
i believe it would be appropriate in
this case because of the high number of
covic cases the positivity rate in
oakland county
because the number of colby cases are so
high at this time the court is finding
good cost to extend those 30 days
because we cannot effectuate in person
hearing at this time due to the
positivity rates it's my understanding
that
defense is requesting in person and i
believe that is absolutely
appropriate in this matter and so what i
am going to require the attorneys to do
is to submit briefs on this issue briefs
are to be submitted on the issue of
placement
on or before january 19 2022
by 2 pm
and we will also have a status
conference on january 19 2022
at 2 pm and that status conference is
only with the attorneys and the purpose
of that status conference is just to set
a new date for the hearing under the
juvenile justice and delinquency
prevention act
and i will note because of the high
number of victims in this case that this
recording will be posted for 24 hours
after today's date
the last issue i believe that we need to
address is the issue of appointing
lgal um i did have an opportunity to
speak to council this court is
reappointing miss deborah mckelvey as
lgal for mr crumbly throughout this
matter
is there anything else from either party
yes josh thank you i just wanted to make
sure that miss lofton did acknowledge
receipt of the general information
yes i have the general information thank
you
thank you anything else from either
party
not for the people thank you judge
nothing from defense your honor
thank you
thank you very much i will see you all
on january 19th at 2pm and again that's
only the attorneys mr crumbly you do not
have you will not be present for that
hearing um we're just setting that so we
can set a new date um if there's nothing
else everyone is all set everyone have a
great day
thank you